[Music]
what up guys welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want
and today's segment is ask an expert and
we got eric here who's an accountant
so there's a complicated question i've
always had um so i wrote it down
i love it and i don't even know how to
ask the question directly
but when it comes to finances
and taxes and investing and stuff i
always hear
uh that um okay that uh they should have
taught like xyz in school
right and then so that's one part of the
question the other part of the question
is even from like my own discovery we're
living in america everything is like you
live
you're born and raised on the dollar and
then the first time i ever heard that
like oh like the dollar is weaker
against this currency or stronger
against this currency
it kind of blew my mind a bit where like
people with a global perspective they're
like
investing like they're buying gold or
buying like crypto or whatever to kind
of because like
things are always kind of fluctuating
against each other could you
explain like that concept
because like you know a lot of people
that are the most risk adverse
they don't want to invest in anything
because there's always a chance of
losing
but what they don't see is if we're just
holding on to your dollar
if other economies are getting stronger
technically
your dollar is shrinking but you don't
know it you know just because you're
you're like stuck on your home got it so
that's kind of a money and money supply
is a kind of a complex topic
yeah so let's kind of break it down to
plain english so we have the us dollar
right and that's what we spend money on
back in the day used to be it used to be
linked to gold where you could redeem
your dollar for a piece of gold
and when nixon nixon came into office
they realized
shoot if this keeps going on gold's
gonna go through the roof and we don't
have enough assets to be able to do that
so we went off of the gold standard the
u.s dollar was what we call are you a
reserve currency
and also it's a a world reserve currency
so a lot of other countries
utilize us dollar that's why right now
we have what we call a hegemony
hegemony basically means that other
currencies other other countries
are utilizing the u.s dollar to provide
their transactions and they
they consider the us dollar as a store
of wealth
as a effectively a trading mechanism
from the do things
like we're almost like they're gold
standard correct correct
and that was that was enacted back in
after
it was right after world war ii they had
the bretton woods
agreement bretton woods was when the cut
the world came together
and said [ __ ] the world's like falling
apart we need to rebuild our countries
we don't have stability in our
currencies how do we do this
so i forget who exactly was present at
the time was it would you wilson i don't
know exactly who it was
i don't remember but basically they came
to agreement saying
at the time because the us dollar was
still associated with gold
we would use the u.s dollar as the
reserve currency for the world
so fast forward today the way the u.s
dollar works
is the u.s dollar is basically an iou
when you look at the us dollar
back in the day used to say redeemable
for gold right now doesn't have that
same clause so the value of the us
dollar is based upon the strength of the
u.s economy
so there's a fluctuation in value as it
goes up and down depending on the
strength of the economy
policy and all that stuff so the
valuation in comparison to other
countries that's a complex topic
because that that's determined on a
number of factors how's trading working
how is their currency in comparison to
ours
is a demand of currency there and that's
why also
right now we have what we call the petro
dollar petrodollar basically means all
the oil that's traded in the middle east
is pegged to the us dollar and that's
why
conspiracies theory aside when egypt
libya and all these other countries are
trying to create their own petro dollar
that threatened the u.s hegemony and
that's why we knocked out their
dictators gaddafi gaddafi for example
right he was trying to create the
african union and go to the
correct trade trade oil and everything
through no he was the evil dictator
that's what i heard
yeah and so here's i mean here again
this conspiracy like i don't even
it's not really because conspiracy this
is implies that it's like made up this
actual history
the u.s has always intervened in
governments that
threaten the power of the us dollar and
that's why our military why we invest so
much money into our military
it's not because i mean granted yeah we
love the military industrial complex we
we lionize the military and all these
things and i know that you know you
serve as thank you for your service
but the reason that we have such a
strong military is to defend
the us dollar and keep the value of the
us dollar up the freedom dollars the
freedom dollars right we just got back
into syria by the way
yes in less than 48 hours we
freaking we got right back in spending
time
what a lot of people know side note is
like actually obama
again i'm relatively independent obama
was known as a drone king captain yeah
when trump was in office a lot of people
don't realize that the number of drone
attacks went up by four acts of
obama's wreck so trump although they say
that he
pulled out of the countries he actually
was still intervening and stuff yeah we
elect war criminals in this country it's
fun
it's because of uh so dwight eisenhower
like warned us of it he called it the
military industrial complex
it's such a massive industry that really
holds a grapple hold on america so let's
talk about inflation let's talk about
money supply
so before i would say about eight years
ago there used to be a publication
number called
m2 which is money supply so every single
year
the us would print a certain number of
dollars to keep liquidity in the markets
so the way the economy works is not by
like putting money in your bank account
the way the money the economy works is
through what they call money velocity
money needs to flow through the economy
to go from you buying a bagel or a
burrito
and then that guy that bought that sold
you the burrito takes it to his detail
or gets car detailed
and then a detailer takes those dollars
and he buys something at walmart or
whatever
money velocity is super important
because if it's trapped up in everyone's
bank account then the money supply is
low and then i see and then there's no
trade happening
yes yes so money velocity is important
so in order to stimulate the economy
typically what happens is they inject
more money into the economy
so when you see like these two trillion
dollar bills or these three trillion
dollar bills
money is not just proof magically
appearing of nowhere they're
printing more money now the problem with
it is as they print more money
there's more supply in the market so if
you remember from like basic economics
there's this concept of supply and
demand
so we think that we have this constant
demand of the us dollar
but we don't realize how much additional
supply is going into the market
so what that inadvertently ends up doing
is it causes
is invisible inflation inflation
basically means
as you hold money your money is
devaluing over time that's worth less
and less it's worth and you can buy less
things with it
correct right so let's say your dollar
right now your dollar could buy this
this this canned drink today now two
years from now
this can drink might not be a dollar
amount might be a dollar fifty so
there's this invisible inflation that
people
aren't really considering and you see
even like candy bars are shrinking in
size
and going up in price so there's
inflation happening so inflation is
effectively
the increase in the cost of consumer
goods
in relationship to the value of the
dollar so we're all being taxed
like but it's an invisible tax it's an
invisible tax and we don't really unders
we don't see that that's why there's
conversations now about raising the
minimum wage
because the minimum wage if you if you
look at it index for inflation
back in the 20s and 30s the minimum wage
index for inflation was about 14
per hour 13 to 14 per hour whereas right
now the federal minimum wage is like
750.
so they're talking about bring up the 15
not because
of um not because they want to create
socialism whatever but because they want
to index it where
inflation hit so yeah they could like a
regular working job can buy like other
things that they would need
correct correct so now how does that
apply to you and i
is how do we number one understand if we
put money in a savings account we're
actually losing money every single
year paying tax on all that stuff how do
we as
individual investors individual
taxpayers magnify
or def or obliterate or go against
this rate of inflation that's where
investing comes in that's where putting
money in the market comes in that's
where
buying cryptocurrency comes in that's
where starting businesses come in that's
the only way for us to really
attack inflation if not if you're the
normal traditional person that just puts
money in a cd
or a bank account like you are actually
losing money over time because of
inflation
and again inflation just to reinforce it
is just like the loss of value
the spendable value of your dollar over
time so like on the side tangent
when folks are thinking of the strength
of the u.s currency
people are looking at like so the big
thing a couple years ago trump was
talking about trade deficits
this trade war with china and stuff like
this because china had this imbalance in
trade
meaning that china was shipping more
goods to the u.s than we were shipping
to
to china so he incorrectly assumed that
because there's an imbalance we must be
being cheated
the problem with that is when there's an
imbalance in trade that means there's
actually a demand of the us dollar
when the u.s dollar is weaker it allows
other countries to buy more [ __ ] from us
and allows us to be able to provide more
trade to them
so the the problem is when you look at
trade it's it's a lot more complex than
just
this valuation so sometimes economically
you have folks from the fed federal
reserve for example
the fed they would actually print more
money to devalue the dollar
a little bit to stimulate more trade
right so it's a very complex topic and
the challenge with us as human beings
is you're trying to simplify a complex
topic by saying oh we have this trade
imbalance with china we have the trade
imbalance of mexico no it's a lot more
complex than that
if we try to change that by tariffs
all that really does is us taxpayers us
individual folks we pay more for the
same stuff
because tariffs are paid for by the
exporters this is too hard to understand
how do i have a rhyming slogan that i
can vote for instead
rhyming slogan uh that's a good question
you know like hey hey ho ho and then
something that rhymes terrorists gotta
go
yeah i like fellaini and that's a
challenge right it's like
a lot of political parties especially
the the right side they love
single-issue voters guns and i'm a gun
owner
i love guns i shoot guns all the time
same like but thank you guys as well i
love guns but i don't make my voting
decisions based on guns or abortion
that's another topic
and like when you think of it guns and
abortion are two of these like specters
that that they make it seem like that's
the main issue no but this time they're
going to take it away though
they're going to take it away this time
they will this time
and it's crazy right but at the end of
the day for you and i
the viewers out there and all of us we
just need to understand that
the federal government is printing money
hand over fist
we don't understand how much supplies in
the market actually
the amount of money that was printed in
the last
since the inception of the us dollar has
been eclipsed by the amount of money
that's been printed in the last four
years
wow and what do you think four years huh
it's not just this year
when you look at the chart it's like
[ __ ] a hockey stick going all the way
into heaven what do you think the
effects of that are going to be in the
next like five years what do you think
that looks like
so we got a combination of issues right
the combination of issues is number one
tax rates have been
the lowest they've been in american
history
there's one point when tax rates were
eighty percent at its top
right right eighty percent percent but
those are folks making like two million
a year five million or whatever it is
they also were writing it the [ __ ] off
too oh
a lot of a lot of um like the actual
realized amount of taxpayers
yeah it was like 30 something percent i
think but yeah it was still 80
and people were getting by right so we
are in a period where we have the lowest
tax rate ever and as a tax strategist i
love it to be honest
but at the same time too we've increased
our national debt by
2x almost 2x when obama left office it
was 19 trillion dollars which is a ton
of freaking money
now that trump has left office it's 37
trillion dollars
right almost double the national debt in
four years
the best [ __ ] is when they run against
the other guy and they go can you
believe this guy did this [ __ ] and they
do exactly the same [ __ ]
yeah so what's happening there and where
are we borrowing the money
so that's another complex situation
because when they say america's in debt
like what does that really mean it's
with ourselves
people like to think it's from china but
it's really it's we're in debt
from the fed yeah china actually holds
on to about trillion dollars of u.s debt
so they effectively own four percent of
the us debt
which isn't enough for like people have
this conspiracy of china's gonna take
over and buy us all out no they're not
gonna do that
right and china also has is incentivized
to allow the u.s to pay down that debt
cause that's a lot of money
right so the question is where do we go
from here what do we do
number one understand that tax rates are
going to go up
and we have to have some fiscal
responsibility from our politicians
although we may not really see that for
a while
this grows it's just like when you make
money if you're making 60 000
a year so let's look at in government
standards
you're making 60 000 a year if you
you're the us government you're in 400
grand of debt
that's where we are right now so as a
family as a household in order to
at least come to some type of medium or
balance we either have to make more
money
or spend less or do both shout outs to
raycon for sponsoring this episode of
off the record i've been loving my
raycons that they send me because i just
started running again nice
and for some reason there's a lot of
earbuds out there that don't sit in
really well
so once you start sprinting or you start
bouncing up and down it falls out
raycons fit really good and it's
discreet it's not like this giant thing
that's
sticking and if you're running like
super long distance like training for a
marathon or something it's really good
because it has six hours of battery life
so that's what i really like about mine
and um yeah i'm really glad that they
sent it to me
yeah for the longest time i was pretty
stubborn about
getting into wireless headphones why
well cause like
all right i lose everything all right so
like i like
big bulky things or things with wires uh
because you know little earbuds it's
easy to lose but once i
used raycon and especially for like
working out
activity mountain biking whatever
you don't have this stupid dangly wire
anymore yeah and
it just makes life so much freaking
easier also
for sleeping too like when i'm out
sleeping over a friend's house or
whatever there's mad noise
instead of having like you know ear
plugs i just use
my raycons wireless and then i turn up
some kind of chill app or whatever
and then i use that as a way to just
knock out that's tight
and you know how like we do all this
outdoor stuff
sports fitness the cool thing is
it's water resistant yep and sweat
resistant yeah so if you're a sweaty ass
[ __ ] you've been frying all your
earbuds
give this one a try raycon is offering
15
off all their products for you guys and
this is what you got to do to get it go
to buy raycon.com
off the record and that's it and you'll
get fifteen percent off
your entire recon order so feel free to
grab a pair
and a spare you're here that's fifteen
percent off
at by raycon.com off the record
one more time that's byracon.com off the
record so what's going to happen if we
tell the bank
ah [ __ ] you because i mean we're the
only customer so what are they going to
do
we can't so that's there inherently is a
challenge right if you're a
big bank asset again
i'm not dog piling on donald trump but
he's just a great example
right when donald trump was filing for
bankruptcy one of his many times
he called the banker and says the bank
was like hey donald we got a problem
he's like no you guys got a problem
i owe you guys a billion dollars i only
got half you know half a billion in
assets so you guys actually technically
have a problem
see yes i hate socialism
and so the irony of writes corporate
socialism anyway but like for us as
individual folks if we owe the bank 10
grand
we're small potatoes to them where they
don't we don't have that same pool that
same power
right so the challenge is now how do we
utilize our money the most effectively
to allow us to kind of like beat this
whole rat race
this whole debt slavery this debt and
servitude
and it really comes down to figuring out
okay how do we
leverage the skill sets that we have
make more money
how do we take that money live below or
mean so we're not just buying stupid
[ __ ] with it
and then take that money and now invest
it build true wealth with it buy real
estate buy commercial properties
buy cryptocurrency how do we do that in
a way where
we can take advantage of the system
that's already in front of us
so we could be like donald trump and
then go hey
um i owe you guys money i guess we're in
trouble
the bank will be like yeah we are let's
figure it out right and then you could i
heard that the top guys can't even
bargain how much they owe like because
of the interest and all that they're
like there's no way i'ma pay this back
why don't you lower that rate for me and
then they'll be like all right well
maybe we'll lower it to like two percent
and then you and i'm like what that's
crazy because if i owe the bank
there's no [ __ ] way man i gotta get
big enough to where it's like
no i'm not in trouble we're in trouble i
want to be able to say that i'm like oh
yeah that's right you are in the club
because that's really what it is yeah
it's a big club and we ain't in it baby
because all of us are like [ __ ] if we
owe the bank we owe the bank they're
going to take us for everything
yeah but then you know that's one of the
goals is like to get to the top so then
you can
be like uh-uh you're in trouble damn
that sucks
but um i guess that's the way the game
goes right and we can only try to
maneuver the best way possible in the
game
yeah because i hear like a lot of uh
like workers
in like third world or developing
countries the minute that they have
they'll keep the money that they have
like their investment strategy is
whatever money that they need for their
expenses or their daily cost
they have that set aside but anything
that they uh have like
overages of they'll either buy gold or
convert it to u.s
yes because it's just way more stable
yes but that's from
their perspective and then from some
people that are investing now
they feel like america is just as
volatile as like a developing country
with all that like with just us
printing all kinds of money so i do know
a lot of people
are also trying to get into like real
estate crypto and like
stocks and stuff like that um when you
do trade from currency to currency
are there capital gains there or no or
is that just yeah
so it is they call that the forex market
the forex market is basically you're
either playing with the arbitrage of the
difference of the u.s dollar to another
currency and then just like with swing
trading or technical trading with stocks
and bonds
as the currency goes up in value then
you sell that that holding of currency
and get your profit so you still have
the same like short term and long term
capital gains so let's say you spend a
thousand dollars and you bought
some x country coin and then when you
sell that currency and now it's 1500 you
have to pay the 500
in gains correct yeah pay tax on it yeah
yeah how does the derivatives market tie
into the u.s dollar
so the derivatives market and again like
this is a super complex
all-encompassing topic that we're trying
to compress into like a little statement
the derivatives market is effectively
like a risk market
they're basically they're either hedging
risk or they're putting up
magnifying assets like a 10 to 101
risk position of saying if this happens
and this happens
and the challenge with it is right now
what a lot of people realize is the
derivatives market this risk market
is massive it's trillions of dollars
they don't even know it exists
and it's worth like 450 trillion yeah
can i do it on my robin hood
i mean you could do like you could call
like do like tesla calls or did you hear
like game stop like
how the that's hilarious right
how these average consumers trading on
robinhood are able to blow up a hedge
fund that
thought that it was dropping is the
derivatives mark i don't even know what
that is
so derivatives is basically a complex
financial product
that biggs banks use to hedge risk and
so leave me by hedge risk
so let's the easiest one is
is the collateralized mortgage market
where basically
you buy a home you buy at a mortgage
right the mortgage would frank fannie
mae freddie mac that mortgage gets
resold to a servicing bank
that services your mortgage and you pay
your debt to them
now that debt gets sold to an investor
and that investor resells it into the
open market now the open market they
create what they call credit a lot
collateralized debt swap cds and again
this is a really complex topic that
works
michael bury was doing in uh in the what
big short yes and so basically what
they're doing is they're taking
this debt they're over leveraging it
using it as
an asset to create more capital for a
business to invest
but it's like think of it like gambling
in
omg coin but on a level of like you have
a margin of a hundred to one
where you put in five bucks into omg and
they're giving you 500
that's basically the banks are creating
massive speculation in the market but
the average consumer doesn't realize it
and the problem is if that that
derivative market ever was to pop
because the banks all the big banks
chase bank of america
credit swiss all the big banks around
the world are so intertwined with that
if the derivative market ever popped the
financial fallout that would happen
would be un isn't that what happened
with the 2 000
in a small way with the with the
mortgages that this is the number one
thing
they were packing the [ __ ] loans on top
of each other as premiums
correct so and then reselling it to the
market as an investor to
um some institutional bank or what have
you yeah that part is so complicated
because when i
got my mortgage from my house it was
with one bank
and then we get like a letter six months
later that my loans been sold to
somewhere else
and i'm like i don't even know what that
means but i guess i'll pay this new guy
right but it's the same amount it's the
same amount and i'm like what the [ __ ]
it's just buying debt from other people
but i think
on the more relatable scale it's like
let's say um you want to take over
someone's loan from the bank because the
bank is like about the default but
you're like i'll take it over
i'll i'll fund it and then now you owe
me money
and then you work individually with the
guy that owes the house and you're like
what's your problem man like
what's going on i lost my job well you
know what i have a friend
who owns a auto shop and he's looking
for someone and then you get him a job
and then
you kind of secure that but you're
basically uh you're taking over
the money lending process yeah they're
willing to
they're willing to take the risk because
they want like that interest rate or
something
yeah they have a whole market that's
called private money lending or hard
money lending
where basically individual investors are
loaning money out and you're going to
see it in the real estate development
side
in flipping and all that stuff where
because of their risk or because of the
short-term nature of it
you're going to somebody that's got a
million bucks in a million bucks the guy
knows that he's not gonna get five
percent the bank so he lends it out as a
private money note for six months
so the challenge that we're seeing right
now and we see the markets really
jumping
all kinds of markets is because there's
a flight of capital
so a lot of folks they know in the back
of their head there's so much money
being printed
right now like why do you think chinese
nationals are buying up real estate in
the united states because they're afraid
of their currency
decreasing in value they're moving all
the currency out of the
country which is u.s real estate correct
and that's that's why i see alternative
assets like collectibles so
like i'm an old school nerd i play magic
the gathering oh wow what a [ __ ] nerd
super nerd and like that the the magic
the gathering market has
jumped over yeah i would say 300 just in
the year wow
i got a buddy who bought like one of two
grade 10 shadowless foil charizards for
100 grand like two months ago it's now
worth 250
because there's a flight of capital
coming from the market we're a [ __ ]
rich nerd super rich nerd wow there's a
flight of capital happening right now
where people are making hand over
hand over fist in the stock market and
they're looking for other places to
place that
wow but the gains are just so crazy that
they're like
okay put in the shadowless charizard
foil card
why not it's more stable than maybe the
stock market or the dollar
or the dollar yeah that's the
speculation right and that's that's
that's what we're seeing right now so a
lot of folks that might be watching this
might not really
be seen that or you might be you might
be a sports person you see a kobe bryant
rookie cards
skyrocketed you see lebron james rookie
card scott rock and you're like why is
this
how did double in value had it triple in
value so you're seeing it from this
micro level but from a macro level from
a large scale what's happening is
people are looking to get returns that
they can't normally get you can't get it
in the bank anymore
and you start seeing a lot of
institutional investors trying to find
alternative investments
so it's essentially trickling down
i don't know if it's trickling down i
think it's i think it's a false
idea of wealth being built and the
wealth that's being built has really
become because of this oversupply of
currency
over supplied money so at some point
it's gonna pop so it's like
all of a sudden someone got money threw
it into the air a bunch of people caught
it and they're like oh [ __ ] i gotta
this is i better spend it yes what
scares the [ __ ] out of me is the
derivatives market melting down and
people not even knowing
why the economy is in the [ __ ] time i
mean that's what happened with the last
recession yeah and people didn't even
know what's happening there yeah until
like a decade later
no idea no idea and that's that's
probably the scariest thing is because
economic markets they work in cycles and
a lot of people don't really see that
because you're working day to day you're
at your job
you're in it right and there's nothing
wrong with that but it goes in cycles
so we've actually been on this bull
market run
usually it's 12 market cycle 12 years so
2008 was the last recession and i
finally remember that because i lost my
business in that
2008 was the last recession we should
have had a correction
about 2018 but we didn't you know what
my conspiracy is
this chaos is manufactured for huge
gains
for people and they have they had to
figure out how to
crash it because essentially it was
going to up up up up up up and then
guys were like how are we going to
[ __ ] build more and buy more you
could make more when you crash it
yes so right now we're we're basically
seeing the largest transfer of wealth
in history and what's going to happen is
we're going to see the real estate
markets
because it's been artificially exuberant
and biden is talking about creating our
new first-time home buyer credit
all these things that keep this prop
market that's at a bubble
and even inventory like i live in orange
county
the inventory levels for real estate has
been the smallest it's been in a long
time
so we're seeing this like artificial
market and what happens is right now
there's a lot of institutional money on
the sidelines with
billions of dollars just waiting for a
market to pop so they can start buying
it up
buying it all up so we're gonna start
seeing rental properties go from
owned by joe down the street that owns
maybe four or five houses
to a big institutional private equity
firm
that's going to own it and so we're
going to see this massive transfer of
wealth and again like
the challenge is like how do we as
average americans
not necessarily take advantage of it as
if we're taking advantage of our local
friends or family and stuff like that
but how do we prepare ourselves
for what's to happen right and it really
comes down to financial education it
really comes down to understanding
the trends understanding okay maybe it's
time to scrimp back
and like hold on the cash and capital so
that way when the opportunity arises to
buy stuff up
instead of saying dude i want to buy a
lambo or i want to buy
a rolly or i want to buy like these new
gucci shoes maybe it's a good time to
start
holding back on some of your cash and
just getting yourself in a position to
be ready to jump
when the opportunities arise so we can
compete with the corporations
yeah i thought it was so we can buy 10
lambos oh that will have that too
okay no but that's when crypto goes to
the moon okay
[Music]
you